foreign
Pro I had about a 30 minute demo just
using this new headset I had about a
trillion questions so I tried to ask as
many of them as I possibly could of
Apple to get all the answers I could for
you and for myself so without any
further Ado let's just jump right in
this is everything you need to know so
far about Apple's new AR VR headset so
the first question naturally what is it
so first things first this is a first
generation device from Apple which we
don't see very often but it is an
augmented reality slash virtual reality
headset with a bunch of cameras and
sensors inside that you strap to your
face it'll start at three thousand five
hundred dollars and it'll go on sale
starting sometime early next year
nobody's been able to shoot video of
using it yet so I'm gonna have to do my
best with descriptions here but
fundamentally this isn't something
that's paired to your iPhone or your Mac
by default it's a standalone computer
with an M2 Chip inside its own Wi-Fi
connection a roughly 4K micro OLED
display for each eye a set of speakers
right above each ear on the band and
then a dedicated new R1 chip which is
doing all of the real-time processing
from all the sensors that make this
headset pretty special but we'll get to
that in a second so all right then how
does it work well basically we've seen
VR headsets and AR headsets before it's
uh typically there's screens on the
inside and then on the outside there's
some sort of shell which has some
sensors on the outside that help detect
what is in your room around you and help
to see the controllers in your hands but
with this one there are no controllers
at all they're not making any for it
there aren't going to be any optional
accessory they're not even going to
design any controllers you are
controlling this thing entirely with
your hands and your eyes and your voice
so you put this headset on and basically
all over the headset there are an
absolute ton of sensors you have two
main forward-facing cameras two down
downward facing cameras two more cameras
for the sides two infrared illuminators
a lidar scanner a true depth camera
these are all to keep track of what's
happening around the headset and also to
track your hands in front of your face
and then on the inside there's also a
bunch of infrared illuminators and
infrared cameras that are purely there
just there to track your eyes so there's
actually a setup process before you even
get the headset you basically measure
you sort of scan your face with the true
depth camera on the iPhone and it uses
that depth information about your face
to give you sort of a custom cut out
this will be a process that you can do
in Apple Stores but basically you get
the headset with the custom cut out for
your face if you have glasses there are
some Zeiss lenses but you finally get
the headset out and you put it on and
there's some nice meshing on the back
some fabric that stretches and is pretty
breathable it's built extremely well
with all this metal and glass and then
once you get it going the most
impressive thing about this headset the
most impressive thing is the eye
tracking
I'm not even kidding this this eye
tracking is sick so basically the eye
tracking in this headset as it looks at
your eyes and keeps track of where your
eyes move around is the closest thing
that I've experienced to like magic like
I don't I normally don't call Tech
things sort of magical or surreal like
this but this was even for a pre-release
product
kind of unbelievable how well it does
anytime you move your eyes around the UI
it would immediately highlight and
select exactly what you're looking at no
matter how small the target was or what
you're looking at and then when you want
to select something all you do is take
your fingers like this and just touch
them together that's how you click so
you look at something click look at
something click so there's actually
there's a calibration process when you
first set up the headset you put it on
for the first time where you basically
just look around with your eyes at a
bunch of different dots so it learns
your eyes and then yeah from that point
on you're just cruising you're sailing
through everything by just looking at
things and it feels like telepathic you
just look at something and select it and
that's it so this is how the whole UI
works pretty much every other headset
has the ability to use your hands to
select things but most of them rely on
the sensors on the outside to keep track
of a set of controllers for maximum
accuracy but this massive array of
sensors on the outside of Apple's
headset have done an impressively good
job of picking up what my hand is doing
kind of no matter where it is so like I
said there's sensors all the way around
the thing they're facing forward but
they're facing sideways and facing down
so I can just kind of rest my hand like
wherever and look at stuff and click I
don't even have to move my head I can
just look at something and just click my
fingers I kind of did it by accident a
few times like I just sort of be sitting
there and my fingertips would actually
touch and I'd select whatever I was
looking at but pretty quickly you get
used to just
just this just just doing this now there
are also some text boxes occasionally
you want to type something and so you
can look at the text box select it and
then a keyboard will pop up and you can
look at the letters but also you can
just look at a search box field and just
start talking and it'll start filling in
whatever you're saying because there's
microphones on the headset and there's
also something they're calling optic ID
which is basically kind of just the
fingerprint ID of the headset because
it's looking at your eyes and everyone's
eyes is a different unique biometric
pattern and so you log in just by
putting a headset on and it looks at
your eyes so optic ID this thing knows
your eyes really well so you've probably
seen all these weird looking frames
where you can see people's eyes through
it like this this super weird thing that
I've never seen in any other headset so
what is happening here well spoiler
alert it's not actually transparent it
kind of looks like it's a glass
transparent thing but it's not it
appears to be because there's actually
an OLED screen facing out this is what I
would call a 2 way pass-through that's
what I'm calling it see a normal VR
headset we've seen is of course
completely opaque usually it's like
black plastic or something like that so
in order to see through to your actual
environment without taking the headset
off like for picking up your controllers
or walking around a room without hitting
a wall they have a pass-through mode so
it'll turn on a camera on the outside so
you can see what's going on around you
and some pass-through modes are better
than others some will do it from a
single black and white camera some will
do stereo pass through from two cameras
some will do color pass through
the pass-through on Apple's headset is
again the best I've ever seen in a
headset it's stereo it's color it's
sharp it's real time
it's really good so then the eyes you
see from the outside are actually an
OLED display showing what your eyes look
like to the cameras inside the headset
so it shows your eyes like this whenever
you're using any sort of pass-through
mode and if you can see your environment
it'll show your eyes so you're not
actually like looking at someone's eyes
but it kind of feels like you are
kind of creepy a little bit I don't know
it's the simplest way of explaining it
if they're doing something fully
immersive in VR like watching a movie or
playing a game then it won't show their
eyes it'll show this graphic over their
eyes instead it's a really interesting
look it's a it's a bold look I just have
this like thought of like you're uh
you're on a airplane and the flight
attendant walks up and Taps you hey do
you want any water and you just look up
and your eyes shine through the headset
it's just a weird thing I don't think
it's smart but I don't think other
headsets are gonna do it because most of
them don't have it in the budget to have
a screen facing the outside but then
let's get to the burning question you've
probably already been thinking what does
it actually do so okay I'm sort of I'm
separating this into three bulk
categories that I made up and I'm kind
of proud of here which are Computing
content and connections now actually I
should preface this all by saying this
is a first gen product so right now the
only apps that show up on the home
screen are Apple's apps just like when
the first iPhone came out with no app
store it's just Apple's apps but the
reason this is coming out or at least
getting announced so early but it's not
coming out till next year is to give
this window for developers to start
developing their own apps and making
cool things for this headset to do that
are way more interesting and way more
functional but it does have a core set
of functions so for computing I think
this is the one that's probably the
least likely to be used by most normal
people but it is a pretty direct shot at
what meta just did with the quest Pro
the 1500 Quest Pro so you can use this
thing as its own computer with web
browsing Etc with these 4K windows in
front of you that you can move around
and do all kinds of stuff with your
hands now this will be its own OS again
it's not running off your phone or
anything it's running a whole new
operating system called Vision OS and it
seems pretty similar pretty similar to
iPad OS just in the fact that you know
you're just touching things in iPad OS
and in this headset you look at
something and then you touch your
fingers together and that's basically
just like a normal touch but I was
really impressed with the responsiveness
again this was better than any headset
I've seen with just your hands if I
wanted to scroll through something like
a safari window I literally in air would
touch my fingers together and drag the
window
and it would scroll nearly in real time
I would like throw it around like toss
it catch it toss it the other way and
start scrolling through things with my
finger resizing Windows dragging the
corners of things
and I was super impressed with that too
now if you're like me you might have
also had some questions about the
sharpness like do I really want to wear
something like this for a long time to
work like it's on a computer and I think
I was also pretty smartly addressed they
use a selective rendering based on the
super good eye tracking so the computing
power is basically focusing on sharply
rendering the part of the screen that
you're actually looking at while saving
power on the rest it's pretty cool and
it works so quickly that I did not
notice it while using it and then the
part you're looking at is actually very
sharp like I said before they're super
high resolution screens they're 4K I
don't know if I have a number for
refresh rate but it felt like 120 hertz
and you know I fatigue will eventually
become a thing with any headset you
strapped to your face but this would be
on the lower level of eye fatigue
compared to what I've experienced with
some others and then for even more heavy
work this was kind of nuts but they
showed it in the keynote apparently if
you have a Mac and you want to do Mac OS
stuff you can just with the headset on
just look at your Mac and it will pick
up what you're doing and it'll mirror
the max display as one of the 4K windows
for you in the headset and then you can
even connect a Bluetooth keyboard and a
Bluetooth trackpad and start working
around like it's an actual Mac just with
a bigger screen wherever you want
at yeah ecosystem stuff so that's
Computing I definitely got to try it but
then of course there's the uh the
connection stuff you got messaging you
can type out messages to people just
like as if you were on a Mac but there's
also impressively FaceTime now I don't
even know that this is necessarily
better than a normal FaceTime holding
your phone or like on a laptop other
than the fact that I guess you don't
have to be holding anything but you can
have people's windows floating in front
of you as you talk to them on FaceTime
but you might also be asking wait a
second if I'm not holding my phone in
front of me what do other people on
FaceTime see well the answer is they'll
see a 3D rendered model of you that was
scanned into the system from your iPhone
that syncs up and matches the movements
of your face with eye tracking and all
the other sensors of the headset so I I
got to try it it is
it works okay so it's it's it's not as
good as obviously looking at a person I
just feel like a FaceTime you're trying
to have like a personal connection with
the person and this is obviously more
personal than an avatar or like a
cartoon of you but it's just it feels
kind of somewhere in between it's kind
of like a Google project Starline which
I just did that video about a couple
weeks ago if you haven't already seen
that I'll leave a link with a like
button so you can check it out but it
feels sort of in that like uncanny
valley you know moving 3D model
territory instead of looking at an
actual person it's kind of how I picture
it but then last but not least of course
content
people are just going to watch content
on this thing and I think this is the
industry now that Apple's jumping into
it that is poised to explode like we've
had VR games and VR videos for a long
time and apple is now also able to do
this they of course put their own spin
on it and they can use the power and the
draw of the Apple brand to get content
creators and big motion picture studios
and sports leagues and all kinds of
creatives to work to make content that
looks really good specifically on
Apple's headset and in Apple's formats I
can personally save from My Demo hell
yes I would watch I would pay to watch
an NBA game Courtside in the VR headset
the quality is good enough and obviously
it's not going to be as immersive as
feeling the energy from the crowd but
you're not paying Courtside prices you'd
probably pay is a total guess 10 20
bucks to watch an NBA game Courtside or
have some subscription to do that I
would totally do that and it would be
fun but even with regular 2D content
like movies just watching a regular
movie you can totally just sit back put
the headset on maybe even put some
headphones on and just like on a plane
seat just watch a movie as if you're in
a theater for one which is pretty sweet
there is that digital crown on the side
that actually lets you spin it clockwise
to move in more immersion and fully
envelop you in the VR environment or you
can turn it counterclockwise to bring in
more of your real world environment with
pass-through in your peripheral vision
kind of a neat trick and then there's
also this kind of weird feature where
you can take 3D photos and videos with
the cameras built into the headset
itself and I did not like this one so
there was a demo of like a a recording
from a headset camera of a kid blowing
out some candles on a birthday cake
basically and I got to watch this actual
scene in the actual Apple headset so
because there's two cameras like
front-facing there they can record
stereoscopic 3D so you can turn on the
recording and in that moment sit down
and record a super immersive video and
then when you watch it back in the
headset it's like you're reliving this
moment in 3D which can feel kind of cool
but I just I can't get the image of like
the dad at the birthday party with the
headset on just recording things like
walking around it just doesn't
it's what kind of memory is that for the
other people around you you know like I
saw this and I immediately thought back
to the the reasons we all know why
Google Glass failed which is it was
ahead of its time but it's also like
they're walking around with a camera on
your face and everybody knows that you
have a camera on your face it just
wasn't cool
dad what are you doing why do you why
are your eyes sticking out through the
headset so all right the number one
question I've gotten after I've actually
tried this thing is is it any good is
this headset any good and the answer is
well yes some of the parts of this
headset that I tried are actually the
best I have ever seen in any VR headset
by a mile specifically the eye tracking
and the Hand tracking now of course it's
going to be up to developers to really
make it good but I think the
foundational like how do you use it part
is pretty amazing but that doesn't mean
there aren't any downsides all right
number one there was no haptics of
course because you don't have
controllers you're just doing everything
with your hands in the air there's no
way to have any sort of haptic feedback
there was a demo that I did where like I
stuck my hand out a wall on the other
side of the room opened up and a
dinosaur was back there and a butterfly
flew out I held out my hand and the
butterfly flew up and landed on my
finger it could track and see all that
information in the volumetric all the
computation to make that happen was
amazing but when the butterfly landed
and I didn't feel anything there was
that moment of like oh right this is a
VR headset but then number two this was
interesting this is pretty heavy this is
a pretty heavy VR headset kind of the
same way that
um airpods max the Apple's metal
headphones are heavier than most plastic
headphones there's a reason why most
other VR headsets are just plastic it's
not because that's cheap it's because
it's lightweight it's fatiguing to have
a heavy thing on your head and this is a
headset made of metal and glass it's
heavy now it is also super well built
like there is no arguing that but I do
wonder about using it for longer than
the half hour that I did I wonder if it
would be more fatiguing to my head
that's also actually why the battery
isn't attached to it that would be a ton
of weight to carry on your head so they
connected the battery instead through a
proprietary cable and that actually can
sit next to you on the couch or in your
back pocket and that brings us to the
other thing the battery life
two hours
two hour battery life on the headset
which is not that great it's not that
long now there's a USBC port on the
battery bank and you can plug that into
the wall for infinite time but the
second you unplug from the wall yeah two
hours from that pretty hefty battery
bank which is like okay maybe most
people won't be spending a lot of time
in the headset but you did also just
show us apple and AD of people like
watching a movie in the headset that's
already like most movies are two hours
plus so something we're thinking about
there's just a two hour but I'm sure
people will make bigger external
batteries for this thing but two hours
and then also I couldn't get a firm
answer here on if there are fans inside
or not but
I think they're stands like they're
certainly vents for fans anyway and if
you're gaming for long enough or using
it for long enough do those spin up do
they ever get loud do they ever kill
your battery that's kind of unclear but
then of course the main thing that
everybody's talking about it's expensive
it's 3
500 so is that pricey yeah that's very
expensive but this is the thing that is
always weird with Apple products like
there is no direct comp like I always
you always say it's expensive but like
compared to what and they they did this
with uh the pro display xdr they've done
this with even airpods Max a little bit
but like there there are several things
that this headset does that no other
headset does the eye tracking the hand
tracking that's super good
even if an equivalent headset came along
today and did all of the same stuff that
this does hardware and software wise it
still wouldn't have face time it still
wouldn't have like looking at a Mac and
then the ecosystem allowing the max
display to pop up so this is kind of
something that only Apple could pull off
so bottom line you know I got to try it
I thought it was extremely impressive
but at the end of the day this is not a
product for the masses I mean obviously
right it's three thousand five hundred
dollars it has the word Pro in the name
too but this this feels like this series
zero like the Apple Watch Remember When
the Apple watch first came out the
series zero where it's really going to
be up to the first gen the early
adopters and the developers to decide
the direction that this thing goes to
decide what people actually want to use
it for and that'll shape the future
versions of it that we may eventually
get down the road then maybe someday
there's like a a vision SE that's like
400 bucks that the masses will all adopt
and it'll be this next Generation hit
product Maybe
but as of right now this is very much in
the sort of early adopter people like me
people like watching this video testing
phase to figure it out so that's the
Apple Vision Pro it's uh it's it's the
rich person's toy and the developers
Muse for right now but we'll see how far
this thing goes in the near future it's
coming out next year it's not that far
off it's not that far away it's really
interesting times either way this was
also part of a huge entire WWDC keynote
so if you want to watch my recap of the
rest of that stuff ideally get
subscribed because there's going to be a
video recap of the biggest announcements
of which there are many other things and
also uh I'll shout out the waveform
podcast to get subscribed there too
because the next episode I'll just say
it it's a banger it's pretty sick so hit
sub hit like hang out in the comments
that's been it for this one thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one peace